[Music]
thank you
thank you
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
hello good afternoon this is Sky News
live from Shemesh on the Polish
Ukrainian border it's the Exodus of
refugees becomes the fastest anywhere in
the world this Century the main
development this lunchtime
they are destroying us and missile
strikes a residential building in
cherniev as Russian bombards several
Ukrainian cities
we were United and therefore strong and
therefore we withstood and it will be so
and we will continue to stand
more than one million refugees flee the
fighting with hundreds of women and
children arriving here in the last hour
with peace talks due to resume today
Russia's foreign minister accuses the
west of preparing for war against his
country Plus
arrested for showing sympathy the
Russian children locked up for laying
flowers at the Ukrainian Embassy
the UK government sends Medical Aid to
Ukraine as Charities launch a
humanitarian appeal
and Russian paralympic athletes are
turned away from venues in Beijing as
they are banned from the Winter Games
hello good afternoon this is Sky News
live from the Polish border with Ukraine
where thousands of people who fled their
homes are arriving in search of safety
in the last hour we've seen hundreds of
people disembark a train here virtually
all women and children many still
clutching soft toys so many of these
people have endured eight days of
anxiety Russia appears to have taken
control today of its first Ukrainian
City and several others are being
bombarded and surrounded while these are
the main developments this lunchtime the
port city of Curson is now under Russian
control while Ukraine's interior
Ministry says Mario Paul is experiencing
constant shelling
tens of millions of people in Ukraine
are potentially Immortal danger
according to the U.N human rights
commissioner as more flee the country
Russia's foreign minister has said that
there was no doubt a solution to the
crisis would be found but accused the
west of planning to wage a war against
Russia meanwhile the British foreign
minister Liz truss has called for all
Russian Banks to be cut off from the
Swift messaging service as the EU
indicated it will further ramp up
sanctions
guys arches Joshy has this report
after the first two I think
sorry we've got a few problems with that
report but it's a good time to show you
what's happening behind us we saw a
short while ago uh a van turn up and the
load of push chairs wheelchairs baby car
seats were
given to the the volunteers here they
were all unwrapped they were all put up
and now they're all being dispersed and
given to the families who are arriving
there's a family who had just arrived
here with little a little child in a
blue baby grow and the younger daughter
I think she's probably about 10 that was
carrying the child presumably they must
have carried that child from wherever
they've left in Ukraine and they got
here and they came around the corner and
they saw the the row of buggies and her
eyes just lit up and she's run up and
and grabbed the buggy and uh I guess
she's not carrying the baby anymore
after after a good few days carrying a
baby on a train she looks pretty
delighted
um so these are going so quickly they
are they are all being taken and they're
all incredibly welcome we're also seeing
the police here as you can see just
passing me helping people who are
carrying uh their belongings all of the
people who are arriving at the station
are being met by volunteers they're
being offered whatever help they can
the problem of course is that and you
can see also wheelchairs also being
distributed behind me as well the
problem is that these people presumably
do not want a lot they they can only
take what they can carry and they are
probably carrying as much as they can
possibly manage So to that end the
volunteers are also helping them carry
their bags helping to escort them to the
right train the right platform so at
least they can get away from here
without too much trauma
well it's a return to Ashish Joshi's
piece about the events of the day
an occupying Force now in total control
of a Ukrainian City
Russian military vehicles Rumble through
the neighborhoods its troops Patrol the
deserted streets
this is the Black Sea port of Kirsten
the first Ukrainian City to fall to the
Russians I'm here with my grandmother
now and um
um we have enough food for a couple
weeks so we try not to leave because
it's very dangerous right now and our
government asked us to sit at home
the Russian bombardment has been
unrelenting Moscow says it's only
targeting strategic military sites but
this is Mario Paul now a Southeastern
city that has seen some of the faces
fighting and remain surrounded on all
sides by the Russian army
a week into the war and Ukraine's
president remains as defined now as he
did when his country was attacked
exactly two years ago the first case of
kovit was recorded in Ukraine the first
weeks of fighting were extremely
difficult but we were United and
therefore strong and therefore we
withstood exactly a week ago Ukraine was
attacked by another virus another
disease one week ago at 4am Russia
invaded our independent Ukraine Our Land
some Aid is reaching Ukraine these are
vital medical supplies leaving Stansted
Airport with a number of injured and
displaced Rising by the hour it is
desperately needed the British foreign
secretary visiting allies in Lithuania
has pledged more than just Medical Aid
Putin must lose in Ukraine we're helping
Ukraine defend itself our defensive
weapons from the United Kingdom are now
being used to stop Russian tanks Moscow
says it is prepared to talk but at the
same time there is no let up in its
onslaught
[Music]
Sky News has verified this video to an
oil Depot on the outskirts of chernif in
Northern Ukraine
Crimea is a part of Russia the
recognition of the Donetsk and luhansk
people's republics in the borders of the
Donetsk and luhansk regions
demotrization which must have parameters
that we have yet to agree upon that
there should be no Armament that may
threaten Russia's security and
denotification the same way fascist
Germany was subjected to such procedures
many ukrainians are defending their land
however they can these people have set
up a crude roadblock around the ernadar
nuclear power plant as they try to stop
or at least store the Russian advance
while those who stay behind to do what
they can to defend their lives and
property their families continue to pour
out of the country
this Refugee train arriving at the
Polish border full of desperate mothers
and their children forced to flee the
bombs and the bullets to seek Sanctuary
but without their fathers and husbands
and not knowing if they will ever see
them again
Ashish Joshi's Sky News
welcome back to Shemesh in Poland you
can see uh the movement of people
throughout the railway station here is
continuing you might be able to see
behind the barriers where it says
Customs clearance uh there's a
wheelchair there we've just seen uh the
first load of people that came off of
the train were women children lots and
lots of children it now seems that we're
now moving through to people with
disabilities we've had a series of about
eight people who use wheelchairs moved
carried up the steps and now it's more
elderly people coming off the train as
well but still lots and lots of people
with young children coming off
well let's take a closer look at what we
know has happened in Ukraine in the
fighting so far over the last 24 hours
first to the Southeastern Port of Mario
Paul surrounded by Russian forces the
head of the city's Council says the
civilian infrastructure has been under
constant bombardment for days and has
described the attack as genocide of
Ukrainian people
to the west and Kirsten which Russia now
says is under complete control the
regional Governor has confirmed that
Russian forces have control of the
regional administration building and
that corroborated by a guest we spoke to
in the last hour
well in the capital Kiev a powerful
explosion was reported in the main
railway station when thousands were
being evacuated there were no reports of
any casualties the Second City of
kharkiv is seeing continued shelling on
an advisor to president zielinski has
claimed that several Russian planes were
shot down yesterday
75 miles away in isium eight people
including two children were killed in
shelling according to Ukraine's
Parliament and the Ukrainian media is
quoting a health official in chennyev
who said two cruise missiles hit a
hospital there
foreign
by Sky News show a missile hitting a
residential building in the center of
the city the dash cam showed 12 16 local
time which would be about 10 16 in the
UK
we've also verified these images which
show Russian ships believed to be near
Crimea this guy's military experts
believe the port city of Odessa could be
the next Target as Russia seeks to
create a land Corridor in the south of
the country
the international Committee of the Red
Cross has donated food and hygiene items
to people displaced from their homes in
mariopol the charity says more than 4
000 people are living in shelters in the
city
while the United Nations Refugee agency
well the United Nations Refugee agency
has described the huge Exodus of people
from Ukraine as the quickest this
Century they report that as of early
this morning over a million people have
now escaped to neighboring countries
since the conflict began and that number
is continuing to rise by the hour around
half of those who have crossed the
border here into Poland more than half a
million people 505 000 people have made
it across nearly 140 000 have gone to
Hungary which has changed its policy
since 2015 when it built a razor wire to
stop the refugees coming in from Syria
Moldova has received nearly a hundred
thousand people and itself is not even a
member of NATO and is nervous about
Russia's invasion of Ukraine and over 72
000 people have crossed into Slovakia
whilst over 50 000 refugees have now
arrived in Romania nearly 90 000 have
gone on to other European countries the
UN reports that most of the remainder
have departed to Russia well as talk to
our correspondent Alistair bunker he
joins us now from the Romanian border to
Ukraine Alistair uh good to talk to you
what is the picture there how many
people are you seeing coming across
Where You Are
well this is this is one Crossing uh
from Ukraine's Romanian they reckon
they've had UH 60 000 over the last
couple of days come here I'd say
probably the same as where you are Jane
it is constant uh we've been here for a
few hours I needed to adjust a constant
stream of people mainly women and
children because as we know uh men are
being refused uh to leave the country
they have to stay and fight and
most of them coming in on foot and when
they do I'm sort of pausing to see I
mean we can see some people coming this
instead the the local police
or the fire brigade they Rush up and
meet them and they give them a hand with
their luggage they carry their luggage
for them and they bring them down this
way I've Just Seen A lady come with um
her pet cat
a lot of people coming with young
children uh baby some tiny tiny babies
uh they're looking dazed they they've
got no idea what's going on occasionally
uh you see what I guess a family
member's Russia and just you know arms
around their relatives the relief of
having got them to safety but for the
most part these are people who don't
want to leave Ukraine at all they don't
want to be here but they are getting a
very very good reception when they get
here
um and they come through and they're
processed either depending where they've
got papers or not but either way they're
processed as quick as they as as quick
as they can be and then they put into
buses are into cars they're all free and
then they're taken into the local towns
and around the region and you can see
exactly that happening here
it's kind of Olivia you've got a bus
coming behind you
um there's a bus just to my left Olivia
to your right here you can see with
people uh being put on it so they will
be taken to the local towns and and
Villages they're setting up a
a Ukrainian school for some of the
children uh one of the main reasons for
doing so is to give them something
different to think about to take their
minds off what they've just been through
because a lot of them will be very very
traumatized indeed there's hot food here
and drink as well again being
administered by the local emergency
services I have to say and SIM cards as
well be handed out since they get here
local SIM cards so they they can
immediately put those into their phones
I'd say it's a it's a pretty good
operation actually they seem to have you
know they've got it sorted here the
remains at the moment but as I say 60
000 through here I think the ladies
number's around 140 150 000 into Romania
in total
you know they can manage but that's
seven days in and it's increasing uh
quite quickly you know that number
doubles or that on triples or quadruples
which you know frankly we wouldn't be
surprised if it does then I I think it's
fair to wonder whether or not Australian
will be put on the system here but for
now uh they are managing uh but it is it
is getting the numbers are getting
bigger and bigger uh by the day I think
uh eight percent more people came in
yesterday than the day before and
they're already seeing more people
coming in today
Poland both are at the the Border where
people come across and cars and here at
the station uh that there is a really
good organized system uh they've got a
lot of volunteers one does wonder how
long they can sustain what they are
providing for those coming into the
country for all the refugees but they
certainly are being provided for uh and
helped and aided as best they can be
when they arrive
well if you scan the QR code on your
screen right now you should be able to
listen to today's edition of The Sky
News Daily podcast and my colleague Anna
Jones is talking to Adam Parsons who is
in Lev in detail and also to a UK
National who's left the Viv with his
wife and children you can subscribe to
the Daily wherever you get your podcasts
now the international criminal court has
officially opened an investigation into
possible Russian war crimes in Ukraine
the Court's Chief prosecutor Karim Khan
confirmed work to collect evidence has
begun after the UK and 37 other
countries referred atrocities to the ICC
of war crimes include intentionally
attacking civilians intentionally
targeting non-military buildings and
using weapons indiscriminately in
civilian areas
Sky News has verified footage that
appears to show cluster Munitions being
fired as a civilian area in the eastern
city of khaki now these weapons randomly
scatter explosives across a wide area
and are banned by over a hundred
countries
[Music]
meanwhile this video also from khakib
also appears to show a missile hitting
the regional state administration
building which is another civilian
Target
and multiple videos have been verified
by Sky News showing residential civilian
areas being attacked and shelled across
the country
military experts warn that this is
likely to ramp up as Russian forces move
in to major cities well let's talk to
Sky's Laura bundock who is in Brussels
now and Laura there is a legal process
that that the the international Court
can go through but I know that when sir
galavrov was questioned on this earlier
this morning by journalists he simply
accused the journalists of wicking up
hysteria for their readers
and he also insisted that the Russian
military were only targeting military uh
military positions they weren't
targeting anything to do with civilians
which we've seen is not the case
interesting on the ICC the international
criminal court Russia isn't a member
um it hasn't been since 2016 ever since
the report said that Russia's annexing
of Crimea was an occupation Russia
hasn't been a member so it's unlikely
because of this that Putin or any of his
allies would stand trial but an
interesting development there very much
looking to the long term though in the
immediate we're now seeing a big
diplomatic effort more diplomatic
efforts today we've seen Liz truss in
Lithuania standing alongside her NATO
allies and very keen to stress the
importance of sanctions being placed on
Putin at the moment saying we cannot
take our foot off the gas and important
to her to show the UK's support for its
NATO allies when it comes to the Baltic
states Lithuania Latvia and Estonia or
sharing a border with Russia in the case
of Lithuania border with Belarus as well
all feeling that the Integrity of their
territory threatened by Putin's invasion
of Ukraine at the moment which is why
NATO has been bolstering its eastern
flank and we've seen the British shoots
very much involved in that in Estonia
they've doubled the number of British
troops leading that battle group in
Estonia at the moment and also on the
Diplomatic International front today the
president of the European commission
Ursula vondeline has been visiting
Romania and Slovakia Keen to see the
efforts being made by though both
countries when it comes to the influx of
refugees they're taking in about one in
ten of the Ukrainian refugees at the
moment and like Liz truss Ursula
vondeline Keen to stress the importance
of those sanctions against Russia to
keep the pressure up here's what she
said a little earlier today
our aim is to cut off the kremlin's
capacity to wage war on its neighbors
that is why we introduced sweeping
sanctions at unprecedented scale
these sanctions are also applied by our
allies and partners around the world
the three waves of sanctions we
introduced already having an impact on
the Russian economy and therefore
Putin's war effort
and we will take additional steps if the
situation deteriorates on the ground
well today in Brussels European home
Affairs ministers have been meeting to
discuss this relaxation of the rules
which means anyone arriving from Ukraine
into EU countries can arrive without the
need for visas without the need to apply
for Asylum to make the process as quick
and as easy as possible it means they
have access to homes Healthcare schools
and even the jobs Market as well a big
package of Aid 500 million euros being
offered to support not just the
bordering countries which are dealing
with the influx of refugees but also
those ukrainians displaced within
Ukraine at the moment and longer term
talks now about where the responsibility
Lies when it comes to more countries
within the eu27 taking in refugees as
well sharing the responsibility as the
refugee crisis deepens
Laura thank you very much
um just a bit of breaking news we can
bring you coming to us from the mayor of
the Ukrainian town of Toledo he is
saying that nine people have been killed
their Russian airstrikes have apparently
hit civilian area a housing area nine
people apparently killed in the town of
hernia
meanwhile Sports boycott of Russia is
widening formula one has canceled its
contract with the Russian Grand Prix the
statement says Formula One can confirm
it has terminated its contract with the
Russian Grand Prix promoter meaning that
Russia will not have a race in the
future and this morning there was a
U-turn by the international paralympic
committee meaning that athletes from
Russia and Belarus cannot now take part
in the winter Paralympics in Beijing
which starts tomorrow the IPC reversed
its decision following widespread
International criticism
we have decided to refuse the outlet
entries from RPC and NPC Belarus to the
parathletes from the impacted countries
we are very sorry that you're affected
by the decisions or yoga that your
government took last week in breaching
the Olympic truce you are victims of
your government's actions
stories had to say on that decision
there are other powerful ways of
isolating Rogue regimes
culture and Sport can be equally as
effective as economic sanctions if used
in the right way
culture is the third front in the
Ukrainian wall across sport across the
Arts and entertainment we're ostracizing
Fusion on the global stage Putin is now
suffering a sporting and cultural
Siberia of its own making
well our Sports correspondent Tom
Parmenter has the latest
the problem that they had within the
bubble at the Paralympics in Beijing is
that tensions were Rising within the
athlete's Village after that
announcement yesterday that they could
compete as neutrals uh it was putting
other athletes in really difficult
positions putting on them the decision
as to whether or not to compete and a
lot of them were saying look I'm not
having it I'm not going to compete
against the Russian athletes and they
were threatening a boycott and the IPC
had to weigh up whether or not they
could guarantee the safety of their
athletes first and foremost and whether
or not they would have enough athletes
to actually hold the competitions that
are in the schedule so the decision has
turned on its head and now those Russian
athletes and those from Belarus will be
heading home before the competition
starts and you have to feel a degree of
sympathy for them because they've got to
the point where their Olympic dreams
have been taken away at the very last
minute but the IPC have been very clear
that the only people to blame for that
are their presidents Putin and
lukashenko so elsewhere in the world of
sport we've seen Formula One move away
from Russia they've said that the
Russian Grand Prix will simply not
happen they've canceled the arrangements
that they had that were at a track in
Sochi in southern Russia it was due to
move to a track near Saint Petersburg
and the contract was due to run until
2025 but that has now been pulled by
Formula One
this is Sky News Today coming up as
President Putin targets Ukraine's major
cities our defense analyst looks at his
game plan
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
clearly not had very much to eat at all
a lot of them extremely thin I'm Alex
Crawford and I'm Skye's special
correspondent based in Istanbul other
people here are praying quietly to
themselves
they're becoming very sensitive
having the media around
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place in news
there's a lot of action going on
every time they touch and they spray
spray made for people who want Clarity
in an uncertain world
this is what makes the job
[Music]
statistics
foreign
forces continue to advance in Ukraine
let's get the latest analysis of the
situation on the ground Kamali Melbourne
is at Sky News Center with the latest
I'm joined by Sir Richard Baron for
analysis of exactly where this war is at
on day eight Sarita thank you so much
for being with us so the Russians are
still masked various points around
Ukraine this is now uh my understanding
uh battle two battles North and South so
we've seen unfold over the last 10 days
or so two separate but synchronized
operations in in the South and operation
designed to link Russia to Crimea and to
isolate Ukraine from the sea and in the
north a separate operation focused on
the capital Kiev and we believe the
objective of that is to is regime change
yeah and let's focus in then if we can
on that fight for the South now we've
just heard from the city of Kirsten we
understand it has now changed hands if
we look at the map of the South here we
can see uh in more detail exactly how
the Russians have begun their Advance
pushing out from Crimea and taking that
strategic city of Kirsten explain to us
why that city is so important and why
the city of mariopol is so interesting
at the moment is being contested so
we've seen Russian forces mostly coming
out of Crimea and they have turned both
East and West the group that has turned
East is advancing towards the donbass
and is about to link up in mariopol with
Russian forces that have come from
Russia that establishes contiguous
Territory between Russia and Crimea and
isolates Ukraine from the sea of azerb
in in the west the forces that have now
arrived at Curson which remember that
Curson supplies all the fresh water to
Crimea and we assess that that operation
will continue round the coast towards
Odessa and we're likely to see unfold an
attack on Odessa from the coast and also
from the sea using amphibious shipping
if that is successful it will have
separated Ukraine from the sea and that
is a crippling blow to the Ukrainian
economy yeah and obviously that fight
for Odessa will be coming but the fight
for Kirsten we heard from Kirsten just a
moment ago gentleman there in his
apartment there is a fight for mariopol
so Ukrainian forces are still in those
areas as we understand it right now so
we would expect to see two things one as
the the battle unfolds for these cities
some parts of the Ukrainian military to
fall back to the next defensive line and
which in the west would probably be
Odessa but the local forces to remain
and they'll probably transition from
opposing the arrival of Russian forces
to amounting a serious Insurgency within
the confines of that City okay well
that's the fight for the South let's
take a look at the fight for the north
uh Sir Richard and as we've been talking
about for the past few days there is
this encroaching Russian Convoy that's
coming down towards Kiev
um it appears to have been bogged down
let's discuss why that may well have
happened it's been about 3 days that
we've known that it's there and it's
still there so it's been a surprise that
Convoy has been stuck for three days but
we think we know why this is first of
all there's been significant Ukrainian
opposition to its movement but much more
than that there has been major logistic
failures in the Russian forces probably
a collapse or a fracturing of command
and control but we absolutely need to
keep our eye on that Convoy because as
it unsticks itself which we must expect
it to it will arrive on the north and
west of Kevin may start to be part of
the encirclement and as you're showing
here more obviously today Russian forces
approaching from the Northeast to begin
to complete an attempt to encircle Kiev
now that's obviously the fight the
military aspects of this but there is a
unfolding humanitarian aspect that as
Jane has been bringing us from the
Polish border and there have been calls
for humanitarian corridors to be brought
in now that how those humanitarian
corridors work so Richard so we should
look at the humanitarian issues from two
directions first of all there are a lot
of ukrainians that are trying to move
from Ukraine into sanctuary in the
European Union and they require safe
passage and so far a million people have
made this and we're expecting rather
more to move but then for the people who
are still in Ukraine who are being
subjected to the the effects of War they
find that they are beginning to lose
power and water particularly in the
cities and run out of food and medicine
so that is going to become more and more
dire so one aspect of this is a humanit
going to come from the West into these
cities in which case that requires the
consent of Russia to allow that
humanitarian access or is Russia going
to provide that humanitarian Aid as as
part of its uh let's feel better about
this operation that will probably unfold
yeah so anything coming over to these
will need the consent of Russia and of
course that's not absolutely well at
this moment okay so Richard thank you
very much for that analysis all right
Jamie you can see the the fight does
continue I'll send it back over now to
the Polish border my colleague Jay
foreign
Melbourne there giving us the latest
strategic analysis of what's going on
this is the situation here on the ground
it has been about an hour and a half
since this train from Kiev arrived and
only just now have they managed to
process all of the people who've come
off that train it's taken that long it
was so packed and they are now all being
moved on to different areas
you're watching Sky News thousands of
refugees are continuing to flee Ukraine
and the bombardment is continuing coming
up I'm going to speak the United Nations
humanitarian chief
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
the United Nations has warned that this
could be the biggest Refugee crisis this
century and that as many as four million
refugees could eventually leave Ukraine
the UN is coordinating over a hundred of
its agencies non-governmental
organizations and partners to meet the
needs of those affected both those
escaping Ukraine and those unable to
leave well the un's under Secretary
General for humanitarian Affairs and
emergency relief Martin Griffiths warned
in a statement to the U.N security
Council earlier this week that the
picture is grim and could still get
worse and I'm delighted to say that he
joins us now from Geneva
um just Martin just being here in Poland
and seeing the faces of those who have
left Ukraine the exhaustion and the the
deep sadness on on many of their faces
how much groomer can it get
well I think it it's it's likely to get
grammar and indeed as you've been saying
and I've been watching the the the
program
um these people moved for a reason
the decision to move in any crisis is a
very big decision very difficult but
there are many people who didn't move
um and are still hunkering down or
dodging the bombs and the bullets in
these various places around Ukraine that
you've been describing and so
the assistance of those who come out uh
which is incredibly important and it's
being provided as you know by
those governments there and the UN HCR
and iom
is a compliment to assistance inside
Ukraine and I would I would make one I
think most important point which is a
consensus among all the people I've been
with the last few days what we need
as a top priority
our agreements and arrangements to
provide
with a safe passage out of these places
the civilians
want to get out
and safe passage into those places of
supplies cash and assistance for people
who remain there who need humanitarin
Aid that's the most important priority
right now for those of us working on
humanitarian assistance inside Ukraine
that needs agreements between the
militaries of both sides and that's
what's now something we aren't we've
been working on for some days but we
have to see that come to a conclusion so
we can get on with it
okay and how do you do you think the
Russians can be best encouraged to help
you with that over the last couple of
days we we've we've had uh some
suggestions that the pope should be
involved that he should appeal directly
to divide me Putin or the China should
be involved and that either of those
could perhaps put a bit of gentle
pressure on on President Putin to try to
open some kind of humanitarian Corridor
are you trying to liaise with either of
those and who do you think is your best
hope
well I would add the Secretary General
of the United Nations to that um
illustrious
um uh set of contact they all need to
help I think
and I think it's possible because
I see there's no interest
outside of the Russian military
who uh kills civilians damage in
infrastructure
that doesn't serve their purpose and I
think they probably know that but what
we need to do is to build on that
interest clearly the Ukrainian
government has a fundamental interest as
they have been telling me that today to
get their people to be safe and served
we need to get the connections between
the two sides to make sure that for
example very simply that we know on a
certain day at a certain hour that
Convoy will be moving in or moving out
with a number a certain number of buses
or trucks with supplies or people and
that both sides leave what's called a
window of Silence a window of silence is
the term used in Ukraine uh in the past
years to get that to happen it's
actually not that complicated if the
will is there
please
do you believe that war crimes have been
carried out so far in this conflict
I don't know I don't know I think
there's a very good case for looking
into it it's not something that
humanitarian agencies uh get engaged in
aren't our obligations are different our
responsibilities and mandates are
different but clearly are my my
colleagues in the human rights uh Office
of the High Commissioner here in Geneva
are onto this already and are watching
very carefully and have made some
statements so of course I think it's
perfectly possible and actually
perfectly like
I think that there is there this this
conflict which was addicted but was
still unpredictable
itself I think
okay
so sorry I'm really struggling a little
bit hearing you I think we've got a few
technical problems but I wonder if I
could just try one more question to you
if if you're able to hear me all right
Martin
um it is just about the the refugees
we're seeing so many obviously the
majority of the refugees coming into
Poland over half a million
um in terms of the shared responsibility
for those refugees clearly many of them
will not want to go far from Ukraine
they'll want to stay close to home
hopefully they can go back soon but in
terms of of The Wider area across Europe
across the UK do you think there needs
to be greater shared responsibility for
the refugees
I think what's lucky is
a calling situation the one
small sign of light perhaps a glimmer is
the fact that you've got the European
Union
with its solidarity with the people of
Ukraine which is willing able and
wanting to provide support for those
refugees and the borders have remained
open as you know firsthand and that's
remarkable too and it should happen and
we've also seen in Filippo Grande the
High Commissioner for refugees who is in
near where you are at the moment we've
we've also seen talks about a special
dispensation for those refugees to be
allowed to stay in Europe for a period I
think of three months so for refugees
unlike in some other parts of the world
um the the there is a place of safety
not so yet for those who haven't made
that incredibly difficult decision that
we discussed at the beginning to move
but I could if I could make one last
point which is so important I think for
all of us
is not to forget the rest of the world
we're launching appeals for Afghanistan
uh and and Yemen this month uh we are
going to need to have the same kind of
generosity for those people that we saw
this week in an incredible uh uh show of
solidarity from donuts for our our
appeal which is almost fully funded
um let's not forget the rest of the
world and by the way we know that the
one of the consequences of this conflict
is going to be an additional costs
additional prices wheat prices will go
up Energy prices already have which will
affect the poorest and those in need is
Syria Sudan Yemen and elsewhere so
Ukraine is right at the top of all our
agenda now and it should be it's right
that it should be because of the
extraordinary breach of the charter and
the consequences for the people of that
country
um but it it's not the only place that I
hope that we will have in our minds in
the days to come
joining us there from Geneva thank you
very much
well let's take you now to Moscow where
the Russian foreign Ministry
spokesperson has been talking to
journalists
the actions of the Ukrainian regime
right now even if you did not know all
the
background of the of this uh dombas
story if you did not see the pictures if
you did not speak to people from there
but the current behavior of the regime
does not leave any doubt that
it's the gangsters
who are running the show
gangsters that are being supplied with
weapons that use humans as human shield
and they hide in residential blocks
they're doing everything in order to
form a certain picture and pass it for
reality
and they're using lives of their
citizens as as Tools in this process
civil population and also foreign
Nationals who are in the territory of
this Secret
we can and we should also talk about the
fact that the International Community
discussed and
but but we did not hear it but we can
see everything that is happening right
in live
um in on TV gangsters that are using
Western weapons
who are not regular forces they just
joined they got appended to these forces
and they received the status of
of
of Ukrainian forces and they they've
essentially become punitive uh
detachments of uh military formations as
of and so on
as
as we were told taught taught by
Washington they are bringing freedom to
the world now we can see clearly how
they bring this freedom and they they
are doing everything on the basis of
nationalist principles you are doing
this on the basis
of hiding behind
civilians women and children and you are
doing this with the cover of secret
Services of United Kingdom and the US
they're using you
but
we've got no pity for you I'm talking
about this uh you Ukrainian
gangsters and uh
illegitimate forces
well that there the view from Russia
views that are certainly being contested
by those who are on the ground and
seeing it with their own eyes
well later on Sky News a guest panel of
experts will be answering your questions
on the Ukraine crisis in a live q a this
afternoon to enter a question email us
at news at sky.com or you can also find
us on Twitter at Sky News well this is
Sky News Today coming up we're going to
hear from one British citizen who's
struggling to help his Ukrainian
mother-in-law come to the UK
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
look at that sheet of flight and it's
moving this way and over there is Dover
we track the changes happening to our
world right now I think it's a
procession of the Taliban there they are
right here would you as prime minister
be able to look them in the face let's
have a look at both of those two things
I just want to say thank you for having
the courage to speak to us we do
genuinely believe in what we do to show
the truth
I thought there was an astonishing story
there I'm James Matthews and I'm Skies
Scotland correspondent
Mr Trump James James Matthews from Sky
News hey James we're finished by claims
that you are a racist
I have a question I've conducted many
interviews I won't forget Killers among
them Mr good right James Matthews from
Sky News can I ask did you kill Susan
fully Dane will show that you know I
don't have anything to answer oh that's
all I've got to say
three of these eight fatalities were
found within the helicopter and were our
colleagues
in the helicopter crew
the whole Reception Area was covered
with blood one of the reception he was
lying and he was gasping for air
we take you to the heart of stories that
shape our world
[Music]
often passed by majority decided not at
this stage to become an independent
country
[Music]
I've covered Scotland for more than 25
years at good times and back
the headline tonight is that Scotland's
first Minister has been deemed to have
misled the parliament the majority vote
by Hollywood's harassment committee
[Music]
well in the UK people with families
still in Ukraine are growing
increasingly concerned for their safety
with relatives sleeping in shelters to
escape Russian shelling one of the
people we've spoken to says the
situation is driving them insane here's
our communities correspondent Lisa
Holland
as the war intensifies relatives
watching all this from afar are becoming
increasingly frantic this is kharkiv
where just a few weeks ago Ola buskin
took this happy family photo visiting
her mother Elena cradling granddaughter
Emilia on her first birthday
lives in Essex now she's on the phone to
her mother who's hiding from the bombing
in a bunker beneath the school where she
works as a maths teacher
I'm going absolutely insane honestly I
don't know what is the wise way to do to
let you stay there and wait until she
will run out with her food and
medication or to let her out of the car
of the basically the shelter and try to
get you out to the train station but
it's no guarantee that any of this move
going to be safe
and
it's almost beautiful hola says this
video was taken in kharkiv a few days
ago in the street where her grandfather
lived her uncle and two cousins work in
a hospital in the city with patients
Sheltering underground they say it's
overwhelmed
I just want all this to stop says ola's
cousin Alexandra civilians are getting
hurt our lives have become hell
Ukrainian Vitali yalahuzian is a student
in Sheffield his parents are in the
capital Kiev his frightened mother has
been sleeping not in her bedroom but on
the floor close to the front door so she
can flee underground more quickly I
helped her to organize a whole trip
for her to get food and water I was
sitting all night going through Google
Maps and social media websites looking
for supermarkets that are reportedly
have some and something left in stock
and I called up my friends to help to
get her some Waters of drinking water
for now relatives can only wait for news
hoping for the day they'll be reunited
Lisa Holland Sky News
well the Ukrainian President Vladimir
zlensky addressed his country earlier
today less listening into what he had to
say
exactly two years ago the first case of
kovit was recorded in Ukraine the first
weeks of fighting were extremely
difficult but we were United and
therefore strong and therefore we
withstood exactly a week ago Ukraine was
attacked by another virus another
Disease by those who suffer from severe
annexation and occupation of foreign
lands one week ago at 4 AM Russia
invaded our independent Ukraine our land
a cute fit of aggression megalomania
delusion of persecution have a
psychological complexes and as a result
missile systems rocket artillery tanks
and other armored vehicles simply like
Locos the first hours of days and days
of full-scale War were extremely
difficult but we were United and
therefore strong and therefore we
withstood and it will be so and we will
continue to stand
well it's been quite a busy couple of
hours here at the train station at um
chemesh where we are on the Polish
border a train came in a couple of hours
ago and let me just show you the
situation now everybody has left that
train now they've come through all the
volunteers and all the donations are
um it's a bit Barren now it's pretty
much been picked virtually clean there's
still one or two people coming out of
the Customs clearance area though and
still one or two people who are being
escorted down to other Platforms in this
station where they'll be taken to other
parts of Poland there are people coming
here from all over Ukraine and they are
then going on to all over Poland and
further all over Europe these are people
that a week ago were living relatively
normal lives inside Ukraine and now are
facing a deeply uncertain future we'll
have more from Poland and from inside
Ukraine throughout the rest of the day
here on Sky News stay tuned
[Music]
[Music]